[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of erisa fury I'm Kelsey Couric and
today I'm joined by the hilarious Steve
Rannazzisi hey I'm so happy to have you
on I'm happy to be here I'm excited to
do this yes I'd be beaten by you
Wow you're coming in is this like a mind
game yes okay okay I don't want you to
think that I'm like you know I'm gonna
be overconfident I'm gonna win but my
mindset I said if I can throw you off a
little bit and be play a little under
play it a little bit okay and that'll be
better for for me I think but the thing
is so I found out before we started
playing that you're left-handed yep so
that makes this a whole different
playing field because on your five-bar I
have to be more ready for you to
actually score like hard from here oh I
score hard from here all the time yeah
yeah right from there that's where I'm
gonna come in hard and then this is
gonna be yeah
airs on the back too I feel like you'll
be strong I always hit it from the bit
yeah I know people will know you from
your comedy also from the league yes and
you have a podcast on the all things
comedy net where it dude oh what's the
odds yep so you're big into like betting
and gambling and sports and that kind of
a thing yeah I'm competitive that's why
I feel like this is good for me okay
you're really bad for you well good for
me that I'm gonna lose and take it Grace
graciously and and you know what I'm I'm
I know going into it I'm gonna lose so
that way I'm prepared for it okay but if
I [ __ ] win Kelsie if I win I'm gonna
flip this table upside down dude I'm
gonna make Detroit Pistons when they won
the NBA championship
look mild like [ __ ] please
okay spicy salsa and posters and I'll
have builder pay for the whole thing Wow
we're gonna do something we have never
done on the show before because you're
so big on like betting and like stakes
and stuff like that I wanted to let you
know from the very GetGo okay what will
happen when you lose you have a choice
you have a choice between two punishment
you're bothering me now now you're
getting under my skin a little bit with
this when you lose stuff like I came in
it like what a real nice attitude
gracious there's no remorse coming at me
is negative so as soon as the cameras
roll for the show that I get it I get it
yes so when when the results come in
what will happen then okay so when you
lose you can either eat a milk-bone eat
a dog treat or I get to wax the letter K
onto your chest okay
just like 40 year old virgin style just
an K right here that's funnier hey
that's funnier mm-hmm it's gonna take
time is it a situation here no no I feel
good about it I just brought it down a
street level e other day oh wow
okay yeah why do you say a while like it
was like no I mean like there's not as
much hair as I expected you have a lush
head of hair up top I'm really thinking
I might be a similar thing down here it
is wash I just brought it down the
street level but I mean we can do it we
can get a nice K in there okay but so
just hypothetically speaking I was to
beat you
which one where do i what am i waxing
your head I don't know honestly
here's the thing I don't think this part
out because it never happens and it will
never happen are you out of your mind
are you out of your mind hubris you have
you are in a psychiatrist Kelsey you're
about to go into a marriage a
partnership we're already knowing you
dominant look at dominance very dominant
it's only with this but I've played this
my whole life you're Sam but you're
gonna run into someone who's gonna beat
me one day and then you're not gonna
have a dog biscuit or something to throw
on that you know or or in yourself
people beat me all the time in like
actual tournament should in this playing
comedians it's just it's just too easy
for you
here we go all right so you got the
balls on your side do you want to be the
perp aiming just okay I'm gonna put the
ball in here okay okay
Kelsey are you ready I am ready Steve
uno uno dos good
which way did you think I was gonna do
that did you come just now do you need
this is pre calm here we go
just get excited and just give you a
little taste do it by the way do I thank
you good to take a ball right here you
go okay ready no no yes I'm not gonna
let you bully me you're not gonna date
me all right here we go
uno uno I'm like actually I'm getting on
there you should be a little nervous
right there one two one bingo find it
find it right here damn brother
Oh [ __ ] slacking off in the back pit
it up already
here we go just the loser gets to okay
bingo one two
bingo bingo no I'm square myself myself
come on Steve yes yup yup don't do that
that's illegal dude come o position
perfectly can't handle anyone right
can't handle the power yeah three two
okay now Kelsey are you ready ready
bingo I am also ready
Pam no you have not
I must bring their own sound effect guy
this is you've never seen this defense
before come on brother thank you thank
you no right there one time so upset
with myself right now all right ready
greatest comeback in the history of
sports happening right now
one two I'm sorry It's A Wrap I guess
right it's closing up shop Wow
just the continuity I'm putting it back
on but just know that the light in my
heart is out what do we do it now so
we're gonna each pick a ball and it will
make it easier for you to beat me all
right so you pick one sure what's your
number one okay I'm four so number one
means that you can score sure this is
gonna you can score in either goal yeah
I will I can score myself
lefty banged him and then what are you
gonna do what did you have to play with
my arms crossed are you feeling good now
you're feeling like you get ready to get
waxed here you go okay all right okay
you ready yes
oh Jesus this is not easy okay oh [ __ ]
yeah I know
thank you that's one for me know I can
always score there you have to score on
that like does that make sounds like you
would have to Oh should we redo no we
shouldn't read the I should be better
like some more smart
all right are you sure no no I got yes
here we go [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] is right
Kelsey Kelsey are you ready I don't
think you asked me if I was ready before
last time but we could check the tail
you think I did one to myself yes yes
the one now this is a problem you don't
get overconfident Steve period yes [ __ ]
is right Kelsey [ __ ] is right okay
tap it more Oh Mike thank you okay ready
this is so huge guys they're gonna do a
34:30 about this one day here we go
dammit god dammit nobody's buying Kelsey
no it's great here you go okay all right
here we go that's call good it's all
good you ready yep no come on now come
on now that's that's my goal
that's my goal I stand by that I stand
by that that's my goal
come on now I'm gonna say I'm gonna give
it to you but we cannot know we can look
at that all right
big defeating you have a problem with
this you don't know which way I'm going
they know it so ready ready ready
uno goes boom now I'm going damn it
alright alright alright history ATC May
20 something mm I will be on the flag
twenty-something okay you ready oh my
god you know what yes yes yes from them
back on the back with my left hand know
it but it's but I'm shooting it I'm
shooting it I know but come on now okay
what is it four to three
yeah [ __ ] it's so big so big so flippin
big Kelsie you ready hmm yes I think I I
have won you won that game I won the
game if I never beaten you in a game I
don't think so
I'd like to my parents my kids that's
really drive me that's you really drive
me to be like that's you know focus when
everything gets confusing you know I
like the high school coaches that isn't
the worst feeling I'm in a bad place
right now I'm in a bad place mentally
emotionally physically Wow
man you must be unraveling right now
well but the thing is it's like what is
our fame third game is winner takes all
yeah but just think about this moment
right now I don't even want to think
about it and don't even want to talk
about it I'm upset I understand you did
side and I got the scoring other goal
but whatever the rules that we chose
were I completely dismantled you and the
thing that you invited me here to beat
me at and make fun of me for your own
purposes for your for your show and now
here we are but I don't know did we pick
out of the thing again what's the thing
up you have to stand on my head this
time how do you want to beat me and make
it so that you feel better about
yourself and can sleep at night what do
we do that how do we do that [ __ ] not
I think I just beat you so I might be
like the second worst yeah I think you'd
be the worst right hey this is taking a
serious serious turn okay you lost to
the wrong person
I really thank god there's cameras here
because people wouldn't believe you
maybe I want to be on that so rude maybe
I get wind doesn't winner get the cheese
no where did preacher stand when he beat
you he didn't beat me that's right he
didn't why did I walk right into my
walking about okay we're up
well know me play two ball two ball so
that means we each start within our five
bar we go one two three go go we both
hit it you have to score both balls to
get a point so if we each score ball
it's a wash okay we're playing to five
okay oh my god did you want to put like
nauseous like I feel like shaky I don't
like that should film okay so you grab
another ball cuz we both Oh time out
time out okay get ready one two three go
[Applause]
that was if I am it's like I'm a Henry
Hill my adrenaline is through the roof
here we go okay okay my makeups running
I'm like down here is to take that did
you see this what the [ __ ]
Kelsey what the [ __ ] oh my god I'm doing
like looking busted my ACL both of them
dude not cool I'm taking brildor
Madrigal everyone dude
I'm like I'm shaking you should be you
should be one two three make up for it
see you make up for it make up all right
one two three oh my gosh no I'm not
gonna let you do it I'm not gonna let
you do that
I'm not gonna let you do that you can't
go there
shizzle biscuits oh my god they're
refocus [ __ ] this is huge okay okay
ready one two three go
did you get that name I did get that in
C I'm so unpredictable which makes it
hard to play hard to fight you know it's
like at this meeting you yeah you know
you know Oh nope no more and folks up
okay so P owed alright we I mean do
truly try to have like some nice banter
during the show but I just feel like
with you and I it's no I it's not gonna
yeah so don't like you okay ready one
two three
[Music]
get in
no no no no no no all right damn it
you're I mean you're technically still
in this this is the guy who beat me in a
second round
think about that hot wax hitting your
chest Steve think about it dig deep
I'm still sweaty you won't even get it
on right now okay one no no that's where
you want yep stupid idiot yep what you
gonna do with your moves now
yeah I'm not stupid dude are you dying
of swagger and covered in sweat I am
disgusting overall I'd say it was an
experience thrilling experience I've
never played a match like that that was
I'm not miss the highs and the lows I'm
[ __ ] hopped up right now did you
think you were gonna win that last game
once I got to three then yeah
he's guarding I never thought I was
gonna win
come on after that second game you
thought you had a chance no I knew once
you had both your hands and I couldn't
score either of my goals I mean you do
many times I had the ball right here I
just couldn't put it into my own goal
like an idiot like a child that's what
you lost him you want a guy who was like
this for 15 seconds all right this is
what Steve chose between this and eating
a dog biscuit cuz I'm going to dinner
after this I don't want to ruin my
palate right oh my god I say just hit
the middle do you want here here like we
hit the middle baby that's nipple just
as you see my nipple right you see him
they're small but they're there you get
real close to it every time you come
closer I'm going she doesn't see it does
she obviously can't see if he's putting
the [ __ ] thing right on top of it
every time okay I'm going here are you
okay with that yeah right next to my
nipple it's not exactly where I want it
yep get it on there good though and
don't okay
ready oh I'm so excited Oh yep I'm
picturing all the [ __ ] talking you did
to me as I do this ready one two three
wow that's a lot to get a clean oh my
god and all that perspiration - oh yeah
oh my god the sweat
yeah the sweat might be a problem but
we're trying yep we're sure tryin here
mm-hmm yep one two three oh you stopped
it Oh
oh my god they're sticking up you get
the roots
you got the roots best day ever
there's blood I'm suing oh yeah it's a
real that's a lot of landscape okay just
do me a favor and get it all once there
was no 1 2 3 go on that one no we need
the last part you chose this get my ABS
you could be eating oh you're so sweaty
yeah use my superpower its defense my
defense mechanism against this
harassment my body's going now dude
fight it fight it you could be eating a
dog period you are not nice at all in
the tap-tap-tap yeah all right we got it
it's on don't go up go down go up oh my
god you're gonna go up oh it's that's
against the grain one come on you three
go goofy yes that one was very
aggressive that was against the grain oh
my god I really want that one but I'll
leave you I'll leave you Steve do you
want to tell people where they can find
you
you know in a bunker shame cell no every
Wednesday I'm reading over there in the
office comedy podcast studio doing my
podcast what's the odds with Steve
Rannazzisi live we take phone calls so I
implore you to check it out and you can
follow me on instagram at Kelsey cook
comedy my website is Kelsey cook calm
for tour dates and subscribe to the all
things comedy youtube channel and watch
all the other episodes arista fury even
though this might be the new oh god I
can't wait oh that's my fault
that's my fault okay we'll see you guys
next time
thank you guys for watching another
episode of erisa fury be sure to pick up
your official erisa fury shirts they are
buttery soft they feel like dolphin skin
they're lovely be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and you can get the shirts at
the link below
free shipping
you